[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur le
plateau de france 3 franche comté pour
le débat concernés concernant la ville
de saint-claude un débat qui va durer 4
32 minutes entre trois hommes
on prend les mêmes héros oui merci juste
flora flora tu me dis bien quand il
reste 30 15 et 10 hockey
oui
[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue pour le
débat concernant la ville de
saint-claude un débat qui va durer
quarante minutes entre trois hommes
on prend les mêmes et on recommence déjà
le dimanche 8 mars
nous avons eu un débat consacré à la
ville capitale du haut jura entre les
trois candidats présents au premier tour
on prend les mêmes et on recommence
puisque ces trois candidats se sont
qualifiés pour le second tour le
dimanche 28 juin je vous plais présente
par ordre d'arrivée au premier tour tout
d'abord jean louis millet le maire
sortant aidé et arrivé en tête avec 38%
des voix il a déjà effectué un premier
mandat de 95 à 2001 il conduit une liste
divers droite il a été adhérent au
mouvement pour la france de philippe de
villiers il est conseiller départemental
frédéric pons est ps conseiller régional
mène une liste divers gauche il a pris
la deuxième place avec 36% des suffrages
35 voix c'est par le premier et le
deuxième
et puis francis lahaut pcf qui conduit
une liste divers gauche il a été déjà
maire de la ville de 95 à du milan et
puis de 2008 à 2014
à chaque fois il a été battu par
jean-louis millet au premier tour
francis lahaut est arrivé troisième et
dernier avec 26% des voix alors un petit
point politique pour commencer je vous
propose d'y passer que quelques instants
il n'y a eu aucun mouvement du nist à
l'autre ni fusion ni désistement donc
les qualifiés du premier tour présente
les mêmes équipes qu'au premier jean
l'humiliait est-ce que vous avez tendu
la main à l'un de vos adversaires par
exemple à frédéric pons et pourquoi pas
puisque il ya des gens de droite sur sa
liste les gens de droite keiko leur
cotisation depuis cinq ans l'europe
coûte et moi je pense que quand on est
militant quelque part au moins ont fait
cet acte minimale dont je n'ai pas tendu
la main parce que nous sommes
diamétralement opposées sur beaucoup de
sujets et notamment sur l'hôpital bien
entendu et puis finalement bas c'est
quoi le programme de monsieur pons et
c'est les campagnes anti milliers il
faut tuer millet ça fait pas un
programme pour faire avancer une ville
frédéricton cf
vous êtes arrivé deuxième est-ce que
vous avez tendu la main à l'homme de
gauche qui est à côté de vous à votre
gauche justement francis lahaut ou pas
alors une petite précision d'abord je
conduis une liste d'ouverture qui
rassemble effectivement des gens a animé
par une pensée de gauche de droite du
centre ou sans opinion
et c'est ce qui fait la force de notre
candidature je n'ai proposait rien du
tout à personne parce que tout
simplement messieurs millet et là où se
se concerter des le résultat donné pour
dire qu'il fallait qu'ils se mobilisent
contre le changement est contre le
changement c'est la liste que je
représente
francis lavaud là-haut comme je disais
donc vous êtes adhérent au parti
communiste vous mener une vie une liste
divers gauche
est ce que vraiment aucune négociation
n'était possible avec monsieur concept
de avec toutes les sensibilités de
gauche
eh bien il ya plus d'un an maintenant à
plusieurs reprises j'ai sollicité
frédéric pons est est l'un de ces
colistiers minant olivier brocard que je
rencontre après chaque réunion du
conseil municipal peut leur dire mais
quand allons-nous nous rencontrer pour
faire une liste de gauche nous étions
sûrs de gagner et moi je n'étais pas
tête de liste
donc la place était libre le champ était
libre et ça c'est pas fait nous étions
sûrs de gagner ça ne s'est pas fait
alors que ça se fait à lons le saunier
vous en vous maintenant pour le deuxième
tour alors que vous êtes arrivé
troisième et bon dernier vous avantager
quand on a un petit peu monsieur millet
les cartes sont totalement rebattues
c'est une autre élection ce n'est pas un
deuxième taux
c'est une élection nouvelle est ce que
nous avons dit prend encore plus de
force et de vérité avec cette crise dont
nous nous sommes candidats pour gagner
pas pour faire de la figuration
alors déjà lors du débat du premier tour
donc avant le premier tour le dimanche 8
mars était le thème central c'est l
hôpital qui avait été le premier thème
abordé avec les dix petits d'amy je
pense que sa survie est toujours
d'actualité
on va faire un premier tour de table sur
cette question commençant par vous
monsieur millet vous comment vous avez
géré cette épidémie covit 19 dans votre
ville est ce que c'était le maire qui
agissaient
c'était le candidat pour le 2e tour aux
états demeurent évidemment parce que
c'est le travail du maire de s'occuper
de sa population et d'en prendre soin
nous avons appelé les personnes les plus
âgées enfin depuis 70 ans
c'est pas très âgées mais une fois par
semaine ça fait quand même 800 appels
par semaine nous avons commandé des
masses nous avons quand même investi
cent mille cent mille euros pour pour
pour tous l'approvisionnement en
matériel engelland masques etc
donc il ya eu un effort de fait est
énorme par rapport à aux habitants dont
il faut se procurer passe ya beaucoup de
personnes isolées qui n'ont aucune
chance
pardon préoccupé parce que vous allez
vous procurer non nous préoccupe les
frais aucune arme n'avait aucune
personne qui sont isolées et il fallait
absolument prendre de leurs nouvelles si
elle peut avoir besoin de courses de
choses diverses de repas à domicile
voilà mais ça c'était le travail du
maire nous on est à pas dans le registre
médical chacun son métier
francis lahaut la gestion des épidémies
par jean-louis millet maire sortant et
candidat vous avez regardé ça comment
mais moi ce que je regarde surtout c'est
comment l'hôpital s'est comportée et
comment il a répondu en ayant été
complètement désossé à saint-claude
comme ailleurs démunis fragilisé comment
il a il a pu répondre avec des
personnels admirable mais avec soixante
trois agents en moins que ce que nous
avions avant la fermeture de nos trois
services
et alors en fermant la chirurgie
complète aussi qu avons nous perdu
nous avons perdu une équipe de 15
infirmières infirmiers vous pensez que
le sort et cède 2 donne deux
anesthésistes
je vous en prie qu'athènes se sent trois
personnes en plus ça aurait changé la
face des choses sans rien changer
beaucoup de choses ça aurait permis
qu'ils soient redéployés pour une grande
partie sur l'ensemble de l'établissement
et cela a permis au personnel qui
restait d'être aidés et de ne pas avoir
été il l'aurait été mais aussi épuisé à
bout qui l'ont été et puis autre chose
la chirurgie complète qu'est-ce que cela
permettait et bien cela permettait de la
réanimation car il y avait une équipe de
15 infirmières infirmiers sous
l'autorité de deux anesthésistes qui
étaient là en permanence
il servira teurs catherine excusez-moi
18 respirateur dans notre petit hôpital
qui nous ont fait défaut et c'est préfet
du jura qui a dit heureusement qu'il y
avait dijon et besançon cas nous
n'aurions pas pu répondre à lons avec
les respirateurs et les personnels que
nous avions si nous avions eu cela à
saint claude
nous aurions pu répondre a fini mon
mieux frédéric pons est ce vous voyez
déjà réagir en hochant la tête vous
n'êtes pas vraiment d'accord l excuse à
dire francis lahaut non non pas vraiment
d'abord je voulais dire qu'effectivement
monsieur jean l'humilier maire sortant a
été dans son rôle effectivement de mer
chacun dans ses rôles et fonctions moi
je suis à la région aujourd'hui et donc
nous avons travaillé avec la présidente
et l'exécutif régional à accompagner au
mieux la situation économique a financé
le stage des infirmières etc pour
qu'effectivement la région puissent
aussi sur un territoire comme
saint-claude être présente
non je partage pas ce que vient de dire
je le ferai francis lahaut pardon parce
que je crois que nous nous avons eu des
soignants au sein de l'hôpital et des
médecins qui ont fait extrêmement bien
leur travail et les 60
ça manquait pas seulement cinq personnes
ont dû être transférés à lons le saunier
pour une observation un petit peu plus
poussé voilà le résultat il est là je
crois qu'encore une fois nous nous
sommes un établissement de proximité ne
sommes pas un chu donc vous pensez que
le l'hôpital de saint-claude tel qu'il
est structuré aujourd'hui ça suffisait
largement pour gérer cette histoire de
qu'ovide 19 mois je crois surtout que
cet hôpital il doit et les élus et les
usagers doivent regarder devant eux
voilà pour reconstruire cette offre de
soins qui nous est indispensable et
surtout et le seul enjeu aujourd'hui
c'est la capacité de cet établissement à
recruter des médecins on développera
tout à l'ats jean-louis millet votre
réaction aux propos qui viennent d'être
partagée tout à fait les propos de
francis lahaut par contre l'hôpital n'a
pas tenu
on a eu quelques personnes transférées à
lens on a eu que huit décès huit décès
duo kobe est décédé à l'hôpital et c'est
moi qui enregistrent les décès en mairie
de sainte odile sont officiellement
déclarés avec des certificats médicaux
qui a dicté qui a dit que la cause du
décès je suis désolé monsieur pons s'est
alors lui avoue dit je n'avais jamais
été informé de la situation pourquoi
vous dites que les tâches des remords
mais vous avez été réformée par mes
services qui engendre l aideront vous
étiez très bien informé mais vous étiez
très très bien par l'hôpital j'ai bien
informées de 8,17 parlent nos services
vous en dit je précise juste que les
relations entre le maire de cinq
secondes
l hôpital sont difficiles voire rompu
inexistante inexistante puisque le but
que je suis je suis devenu l'ennemi du
directeur alors que le directeur de yona
le maire d'oyonnax s'entretenait tous
les matins à 9 heures ainsi qu'à dole je
n'ai jamais eu une seule alors à carnon
ciotti veut dire qu'un mot sur les
respirateurs dont monsieur là haut a
fait allusion et sur le rôle de la
région s'il vous plaît dans le rôle de
la région la région est intervenue avec
nos entre autres des commandes de
masques pour tous publics qui sont
arrivés après la bataille et qui ne sont
pas un cadeau puisque ont eu leurs
factures j'ai sur mon bureau une facture
de 19000 euros à payer à la communauté
de communes qui va les reverser à la
région jeu par des masques tout public
on est bien d'accord images lavables et
réutilisables moi je voudrais attirer
l'attention
le coc vite c'est une chose c'est une
crise il y avait quand même eu à la
résidence du mont-gaillard maison de
retraite au niveau 3 sur 29 lits 24
contamination et onal record de
contamination du personnel avec 22
personnes contaminées par 1000
personnels sur 40 dans tunz ht jura sud
oui surtout sur l'ensemble des
structures hôpital et autres je resterai
sur la maison de retraite 10 font donc
le personnes contaminées jura sud ses
2600 salariés saint claud c'est 10 % et
les 10% de salariés des personnels
représentent 50% des contaminations
vendredi que certains n'ont pas bien
fait leur boulot
le boulot c'est que nos responsables
sionistes coville a baladé le service la
déménager trois fois transporté le virus
dans tout l'établissement et en os le
résultat inévitable qu'on a pu constater
je voulais juste vous faire réagir fait
des réponses et sur le rôle de la région
donc ce ne sont pas des dons c'est
simplement la région qui s'est organisée
pour commander massivement
masques et après les faire payer par les
collectivités saint claude et d'autre il
ya eu deux choses il ya eu des commandes
de masques qui ont été offertes au
personnel soignant
comment au personnel dans les camps tout
dans les ehpad et c'est à ceux là ont
été offerts gratuitement
voilà on a joué cette solidarité l'aller
il est offert payant c'est ensuite la
région a tout de suite compris que quand
les quelques distributeurs les quelques
fabricants étaient écrouées soûles et
sous les commandes et une commande de 4
millions de masses par rapport à une
petite commune qui commandent 200
masques
je veux dire voilà et ce qui était
important c'est que ces petites communes
elles puissent être aussi bien servi et
un prix aussi bien attractifs que ceux
qui sont en capacité de faire de très
grandes commandes
vous avez comment vous avez fait une
première commande de masques monsieur le
maire et vous êtes porté à l'anam écueil
que nous c'est à dire que votre commande
elle n'a pas suivi et vous être abattus
effectivement sur ceux de la région et
ce concert vous êtes honneur bâtir les
commandes et des masques en chine j'en
ai pour 15000 euros je lis reçu trois
semaines avant la région ce qui a permis
de faire une distribution avant tout le
monde
15 millions d'euros j'ai fait livrer en
suisse pour pas combien de gaz 15
millions de dunkerque à 2000 euros par
dont 15 millions c'est un peu excessif
de l'âme en campagne électorale c'est un
peu beaucoup de nos possibilités
quinze mille euros aux vins affaire aura
4 en chine et nous les avons eu trois
semaines d'avoir la région parce que
nous sommes bougeait bien avant la
région nous avons été servis en temps et
en heure francis lahaut est le plus fort
sur ce il ya d'être dit si nous avions
eu nos trois services je crois que j'ai
expliqué frédéric pons n a pas répondu
nous aurions été moins démuni pour
répondre à cette pandémie
est ce qu'il faudrait que nous disent
frédéric pons et car il entretient
l'incertitude sur cette question c'est
qu'il est contre la réouverture de la
maternité de la pédiatrie et de la
chirurgie complète il faudra qu'ils
l'avouent à tous ses électeurs il en
voudra le dire clairement
frédéric et cesser de répondre à côté
alors que les choses soient claires
je ne renonce 12 et maria pour ça oui je
ne renonce absolument pas moi et mes
colistiers à ce qu'il y ait un jour de
nouveau des naissances à saint claude
voilà simplement je suis conscient de ce
qui a fait que cette maternité a fermé
j'habite saint claud depuis 25 ans
depuis 25 ans j'entends que cette
maternité et sous l'écueil de pouvoir
fermer
voilà qu'est ce qu'on a fait pendant 25
ans cette maternité elle a fermé parce
qu'on n'a pas su garder le nombre de
naissances suffisant pour qu'elle
fonctionne bien et deuxièmement parce
qu'on a pas su garder les médecins voilà
la maternité avant tout c'est une
question de sécurité sécurité dans les
accouchements
vous vous prenez effectivement une
maternité au rabais moi je suis
interpellé
pratiquement tous les jours par des
femmes et des hommes qui ont perdu un
enfant et qui me disent une maternité
oui mais pas n'importe et a dû à
saint-claude une maternité à bord de la
route avec et sa bouche mans sur la
borne lancé faut assumer en effet une
maternité a terni une métairie mépris
une maternité de niveau 3 que vous
défendez dans un avenir aux calendes
grecques qui ne viendra jamais
aujourd'hui nous avons une maternité
nous avions et nous aurons demain de
niveau 1 et qui permet de répondre à 80
% des accouchements qui se font dans des
conditions normales et lorsqu'il ya un
problème
la parturiente et transféré c'est
infiniment mieux que d'accoucher sur le
bord de la route
le septième accouchement sur le bord de
la route le 15 mai lecture mkii été
faite hier par monsieur millet de ses
patients de cette part turrian tu qui
demande que l'on réouvre la maternité et
le temps que je vous ai dit demain
l'avenir l'avenir qu'est ce que c'est au
dernier conseil de surveillance le
directeur nous a dit la stérilisation
il faut l'externaliser car cela a un
coût la pharmacie la stérilisation
stérilisation la stérilisation de tout
ce dont nous avons besoin pour faire des
opérations je ne suis pas chirurgien
dans de bonnes conditions sanitaires
externaliser la pharmacie externalisés
mais le laboratoire et je termine mon
cher frédéric et le laboratoire
il faut l'externaliser car cela a un
coût il faut le déporter le mot est
admirable à saint claude
il faut le déporté mais le déporter
quand nous avons des urgences 24 heures
sur 24 que nous avons gagné maintenu
grâce à notre mobilisation sans quoi
elles étaient condamnées et bien comment
fait-on travail et des urgences 24
heures sur 24
quand nous n'avons pas de laboratoire
expliquez-nous cela monsieur du côlon et
on a des micros c'est bon et doux vous
n'êtes pas obligé de crier tout va aux
joueurs la réponse monsieur pensez mais
moi un cap sur va pas faire quand je
vous entends je ne comprends pas
pourquoi on a perdu des services dans
cette dans cet hôpital alors que vous
êtes aux responsabilités depuis 25 ans
un quart de siècle dans cet hôpital
quand vous dites vous c est monsieur là
haut mais eh oui môssieur jamais rien
fait le plateau technique
il écoute avec le comité de défense que
j'ai créées dont j'étais à l'origine est
tu n'as rien fait mais oui je sais lille
je t'assure bon parce que tu n'as pas de
répondre non mais si ma réponse je suis
désolé un je suis désolé a bien fait
pendant 25 ans est une vraie il ya
demain francis je suis désolé je n'ai
pas ton âge mais ces milliers vous pensé
lors donc monsieur pensez vous accuse
d'avoir rien fait pendant 25 ans glock
quoi il ya eu des pertes d'habitants il
ya une le pont 7 ans l'ex et permanent
il n'est pas crédible le plus depuis
longtemps sur l'hôpital l'hôpital n'est
pas menacée puis 25 ans il est depuis
2000 16 depuis 2016 j'ai participé à
toutes les réunions pour le défendre
de toute manière un plus haut niveau
depuis 2007 depuis 16 ou sont battues
sont battus contre les fermetures
aujourd'hui nous battons pour les
réouvertures et quand je vois ce qui
s'est passé hier soir la manifestion
manifestation de soutien aux hôpitaux
publics
ou médecin numéro deux sur la liste de
monsieur pons et a osé déployé une
banderole de sa fabrication sur la
qualité écrit chirurgie fermé maternité
fermée vies sauvées
on est devenus fous dont elle met vite
répondre frédéric pons et et on passe à
la suite rapidement
monsieur fournier enfin ou dr millet je
ne sais pas c'est un médecin qui l'écrit
c'est un médecin qui vous l'écris
d'accord et alors voilà et alors cette
tunique j'ai rien de le dire c'est le
cas d'anthony et c'est un médecin qui
vous le dit
la sécurité des personnes avant tout oui
il ya d'autres médecins la réouverture
de la maternité une réponse je t'ai fait
une réponse raisons sont à l'engrais
mais pour au moins un médecin
ça fait trois ans que vous battez sur ce
sujet quelles sont les avancées on a
gagné le survirage à cannes en vain car
le service il est perdu non
alors juste alors on va passer à la
suite il n'y a pas je vous propose
maintenant d'écouter les 100 claudia
qu'une de nos équipes a rencontré dans
la rue cette semaine
alors outre l'hôpital qui est bien sûr
un des dossiers prioritaires
quels sont les dossiers qu'ils jugent
eux aussi indispensable à la vie de
saint claude
on les écoute tout de suite qu'est ce
que vous attendez là qu'il fasse revivre
la ville parce que la ville de
saint-claude shekau quoi donc
donc pour moi c'est que l'abus de
travail pour que les logements s'achète
pour dynamiser retaper sur sont plus
vivants contre les gens ça n'aille pas
parce que pas mal de gens sont partis
travaillent pour relancer les
entreprises développer singles aux puits
de faire renaître un peu les fait
renaître la ville parce qu'il ya de gros
besoin de relancer le tourisme est en
chute libre
le nombre d'habitants le travail notre
belle région devrait développer un peu
plus le tourisme à 5 l'autre parce qu'il
y ait donc dans le haut mais chez nous
on n'a pas beaucoup
y'a pas beaucoup d'activités
touristiques et tout ça des nouvelles
idées un peu de dynamisme après plus
priviligiées la jeunesse aussi plus
d'activité parce que j'ai l'impression
qu'il est tournant qui s'embêtent qu'ils
n'ont rien d'autre à faire je pense que
ce soit soit un maire qui prennent des
décisions plus axé sur la culture le
social est peut-être moins sur les
questions de sécurité
l'avs
la préoccupation numéro un des sens
claudien monsieur millet c'est le
travail le travail et le nombre
d'habitants qui est en chute libre
saint claude a perdu deux mille
habitants en dix ans vous leur répondez
quoi vous allez faire quoi mais je
voudrais du concret si le du plein creux
on a perdu pourquoi des habitants on a
perdu parce que les autres deux
entreprises majeures l'une à licencier
800 personnes mais mes connaissances à
celles passées on ne se regarde en l'air
ne s'est pas remis de cette situation
plus la crise de 2008 les entreprises
ont souffert et les gens certaines
beaucoup sont partis travailler ailleurs
nécessairement il faut remonter
aujourd'hui nous ne sommes pas nous les
pilotes sont pas les chefs d'entreprise
quand les marchés diminuent ou
s'effondrent les entreprises souffrent
c'est le travail qui fait venir les
habitants pourquoi est-ce que nous avons
requalifier le centre-ville d'année
dernière pour redonner de l'attractivité
à la ville et ya quand même heureusement
des entreprises qui embauchent mais qui
ont du mal à le faire parce que il
notamment il ya plus d'hôpital les
jeunes couples qui arrive vous n'avez
plus d'hommes plus de materner pas il ya
toujours l'hôpital vous n'êtes plus de
maternité
on ne vient pas parce que on aura des
enfants voilà alors je pense que là on a
fait énormément
chose si les gens ne le reconnaissent
pas ce qu'ils ont la mémoire courte et
puis l'hôpital est un facteur
d'attractivité énorme dans une ville
comme au lycée d'ailleurs francis lahaut
donc vous voyez les préoccupations des
gens le travail le nombre d'habitants
voire le tourisme vous dites quoi si
vous êtes maire le 28 au soir
alors tout d'abord tout a changé
la pandémie d'une violence et d'une
ampleur inouïe difficile mais le tsunami
il est il est devant nous qu'il est
devant nous le pire reste à venir
une crise sociale et économique comme
nous n'en avons jamais connue demain si
nous sommes élus nous allons ensemble et
en déplaçant tous les clivages
rassembler les industriels les chambres
de commerce
nous allons rassembler les collectivités
locales les syndicats ouvriers et les
syndicats aussi des entreprises pour
prendre toutes les mesures pour faire en
sorte que les entreprises qui n'ont
aucune perspective
aucun avenir devant elles puissent
travailler et que nous travaillons aussi
à relocaliser l'emploi ce qui va de pair
aussi avec la préoccupation écologique
on va donner la parole à frédéric pons
c'est le travail préoccupation numéro un
des habitants de saint claude
si vous êtes élu maire vous faites quoi
le lundi 29 au matin
alors moi dans tous les cas déjà ce que
j'entends c'est que les habitants de
saint claude ont soif d'avenir et ça
pour moi c'est vraiment important parce
que je les rejoins sur cet aspect là des
choses
oui une ville plus fort c'est une ville
qui a plus d'emploi qui sait recruter et
qui fait de la formation sur ce champ là
nous nous avons un projet qui s'appelle
territoire zéro chômeur et nous voulons
expérimenter ce dispositif là avec le
monde de l'industrie aujourd'hui se
hisse expérimente plutôt dans le monde
associatif et caritatif et et public et
moi j'ai envie de le faire en sorte que
ces deux mondes là se réunissent pour un
bien commun qui est l'emploi sur une
cité comme l'anneau
vous pensez que c'est le levier d'un
maire que le maire peut faire ce genre
de choses la formation peut-être à me
faire venir les entreprises c'est quand
même pas facile alors je dis pas faire
venir des entreprises jeudi qu' au
contraire il faut consolider aussi déjà
ce lycée qui sont là puisque nous avons
un air ça doit être aujourd'hui un
animateur c'est quelqu'un qui doit être
en capacité de faire en sorte que chacun
partage le même enjeu se mettent autour
d'une table et travail à réaliser les
objectifs et trouve les solutions
partagées pour faire avancer le
terrifiant alors dans le micro trottoir
c'est comme ça qu'on appelle un
cantonnement de la vie la vie des gens
dans le micro trottoir
les gens parlent beaucoup de tourisme il
trouve que en effet le jura est
attractif et c est que la ville de
singles août montrent peut-être
justement un peu d'attractivité un peu
d'activités touristiques vous leur dites
quoi monsieur min et la requalification
du centre-ville qui est une complète
c'est l'aménagement du centre-ville mais
cet effet mais tous maintenant vous êtes
rotor leur jeu vous des terrasses
partout des élèves millions d'euros 1,5
million et demi d'euros cet effet pour
le tourisme et aide les gens qui
viennent à saint-claude maintenant
trouve la ville belle alors que nous
avions honte de nos centres villes il ya
deux ans et quand monsieur concède donne
des leçons sur la création d'emplois
qu'est ce qu'il a fait par le passé je
lui rappelle que pendant cinq ans il a
présidé une association qui s'appelle
site et au jura qui prenait la
succession de la maison de l'emploi dont
le rôle la vocation était de susciter
des créations résultat zéro madame
triple zéro seul mais a pas empêchés de
consommer trois cent mille euros par an
de subventions publiques pendant cinq
ans il a mangé un million et demi de
subventions publiques pour 0 résultats
et monsieur procès vient aujourd'hui
nous donner des leçons sur le dynamisme
de la ville et sur la création d'emplois
mais franchement c'est à mourir de rire
en fait au-delà parole à francis la haye
là-haut et puis après on vous répondrais
frais des réponses et dans mon dernier
mandat
nous avons investi deux millions trois
cent mille euros pour requalifier
totalement notre camping municipal et
qui en saison normale et plein très
plein et qui peut encore se développer
donc voilà ce que nous faisons ce que
nous avons fait et et demain qu'est ce
que nous allons faire
nous allons nous battre pour que 5
l'autre soit plus accessible à travers
des transports doux en demandant en se
battant ce que nous avons fait depuis
longtemps pour la réouverture de la
ligne sncf saint claude
oyonnax les touristes veulent venir pas
seulement en voiture à saint claude ils
veulent venir avec des transports en
commun donc revoir l'intermodalité
comment les transports en commun peuvent
travailler ensemble avec des transports
doux avec des bus verts pour là où il
faudra des bus est donc en investissant
dans l'économie durable est aussi dans
une ville qui doit rester attractive à
travers qu'aussi alors ça ne plaira pas
ce 1000e et réduisons réduisons et on
dépasse un peu le tourisme mais le taxe
foncière peut être réduite par exemple
aussi on parlait tout à l'heure de
solidarité on en parlera peut-être sinon
je les gens parlent maintenant
mais si on en parle de tout allez-y
panade des audiences et à lézat
solidarité c'est très simple s'il
regrette absence hier on peut le faire
nous l'avions fait nous dans notre
précédent mandat
on peut le faire sur six ans sur 12 ans
on à 33,50 on peut revenir à 25
mais c'est aussi réduire la facture
d'eau et puis c'est aussi réduire les
indemnités des élus frugalité
énergétique frugalité indemnitaire
150000 euros on divise par 2 75 mille
feux d'eric poncet vous pouvez répondre
a donc monsieur millet qui vous accusent
donc d'avoir dilapidé manger un million
et demi de subventions publiques
et puis après je vous relancerez sur
l'économie et le tourisme nonce ces
chiffres d'abord sont faux ensuite j'ai
fait quand je suis arrivé à la
présidence cité au jura le premier qui
m'a retiré les subventions pour faire
fonctionner cette association
ces gens l'humilier voilà plus de
subventions de la mairie plus de
subventions du département
voilà bien le vison du disque que vous
avez qu est ce que vous y êtes est élu
conseiller départemental
est-ce que vous avez créés ou pas des
emplois quand vous étiez donc dans cette
rose cité au jura c'était de fédérer
l'ensemble des acteurs pôle emploi
direct
collectivités autour du sujet
effectivement de la création d'emplois
s'étaient pas à citer au jura de créer
des emplois voilà je vous donne
l'exemple facilitateur moi je suis un
exemple d'action par exemple quand je
suis arrivée à la présidence la première
chose que j'ai proposé à mon conseil
d'administration dont de se mouiller
faisait partie et francis c'était de
créer des conditions pour promouvoir
notre territoire afin de recruter des
profils de santé voilà la réponse ça a
été on arrête les aides alors sur le
tourisme
vous dites quoi vous proposez quoi alors
sur le tourisme moi je pense
qu'effectivement il y a un vrai
potentiel à saint-claude simplement et
ce potentiel là il doit s'inscrire dans
un cadre plus global qui est
l'intercommunalité
voilà on a on a on a une culture
on a une architecture comment de la
ville qui effectivement est en cap et
des savoir faire qui sont en capacité de
créer l'identité touristique
il faut qu'on travaille là-dessus avec
l'ensemble des acteurs vous m'avez tendu
la perche pour faire la transition
puisque je voudrais justement que l'on
parle maintenant des relations entre la
ville de saint-claude et
l'intercommunalité donc saint-claude
fait partie d'une communauté de communes
qui s'appelle saint claude haut jura qui
regroupe 22 communes c'est bien ça et
plus de vingt mille habitants
nous avons eu hier la un communiqué du
président de cette structure
intercommunale qui s'appelle raphaël
perrin c'est le maire divers gauche de
ce monde celle qui a été élue à ce poste
de président il ya six ans 2014 alors
que vous monsieur millet vous veniez
d'être réélu à saint-claude et vous
n'avez pas été élu à cette présidence
depuis les relations sont extrêmement
tendues
ce pôle réseaux c'est pas la raison non
mais je ne fais pas de lien de cause à
effet toujours est il que les relations
entre la ville de saint claude qui
crament la ville centre de cette
intercommunalité et et la comcom sont
extrêmement mauvaise est-ce que et
monsieur père a dit qu'il faut surtout
pas voter pour vous pour le 28 juin
comment vous avez ressenti ce communiqué
est ce que c'est juste comme le dit
frédéric pons et l'intercommunalité qui
est le bon échelon pour répondre à la
préoccupation des gens à savoir
l'économie
on n'a pas empêché l'auteur communalité
de travailler depuis six ans il tourisme
est en panne quelque part comme certains
disent moi je ne le crois pas bah c'est
la terre qu qui a la compétence quand
monsieur père a dit que si je suis élu
c'est je rappelle communauté de communes
va coûter moi ça me privera pas rassurez
vous mais monsieur perrin fait de
l'ingérence dans une élection locale
d'une commune qui n'est pas la sienne je
trouve ça déjà très choquant dire que si
je suis élu ne sèchera pas quel bel
exemple de démocratie et de respect de
ses adversaires
et puis le souci qu'il y avait il ya six
ans c'est pas que j'ai été élu n'ait pas
été élu à la présidence je m'en fichais
complètement
j'avais même passé au deal avec monsieur
perrin et je vais d'ici je ne suis pas
si je suis président tu seras vice
président premier vice président il
m'avait dit ok mais l'inversé jamais
produit sauf que pour une ville qui est
représente 50 % des habitants et 50% du
budget nous avons zéro vice-présidence
on nous a foutu dehors en nous a mis à
la porte nous avons un strapontin pour
la ville qui est le premier financeur à
50 à 40 alors chevalier retourner un peu
facile pour monsieur conseil fait de la
politique jusqu'à dimanche prochain
c'est pour mieux penser pardon monsieur
perrin c'est à peu près pareil mais les
fonds de la politique en soupe
moi ça me dépasse complètement c'est
complètement idiot une nulle de
déclaration mais c'est vrai que vous
avez de mauvaises relations avec la
comcom alors si vous êtes à nouveau élu
comment ça va la saison tout à fait
normalement nous tenons notre place
depuis deux ans un nouveau observé
pendant quatre ans vu n'y être pas allé
bon on n'y est pas allé quand on vous
met dehors vous revenez vous alors quand
on se met dehors pas vu nous en sommes
partis quand quand on refuse la moindre
vice-présidence à la ville qui
représente 50% de la communauté de
communes faut être tombés sur la tête
pour revenir non je suis désolé voile
alors nous avons est absent pendant
quatre ans c'est vrai nous sommes
revenus nous tenons notre place à nous
jouons notre rôle depuis deux ans mais
je voudrais juste l'alizé une quelque
chose par rapport à l'hôpital pour clore
le chapitre vraiment c'est très
important
les services ont été fermées par
décision de la ministre at her
provisoire en 2018 ils ont été fermées
et la loi impose article du code de la
santé publique 6143 impose qu'ils se
concertent avec son directoire
il ya eu concertation avec le directoire
pour la suppression notamment de la
maternité et de la chirurgie qu'on nous
attendait et dans le directoire
le directoire a cautionné les fermetures
donc il a trahi les cinq laudien lé haut
jurassien et dans le directoire la
personne la plus active et la numéro 2
ne se pensait le fameux médecin
donc là on a compris je suis je suis
désolé on parle maintenant de l'économie
et de la structure honda communal
francis là où vous avez été président de
la structure intercommunale dans le
mandat précédent
j'étais président et à la suite d'une
fusion de trois communautés de communes
celles d'un défilé où l'intervenant
pardon l'interco c'est bon échelon pour
parler d'économie c'est c'est la
compétence de la communauté de communes
le développement économique c'est une
compétence essentielle comme le tourisme
d'ailleurs et vous avez été vexé raphaël
perrin dans son communiqué ne vous cite
même pas quand ils ne me plains pas mais
dit que je lui laisse une situation
financière difficile alors il est vrai
quand on perd sept cent cinquante mille
euros de taxe professionnelle c'était le
nom de cette taxe sur les entreprises
autrefois à cause oui vous avez laissé
un trou de 6 me de deux mois 5000 vous
voyez 750000 euros par an vous voyez ce
que ça peut laisser aux comptes
administratifs en moins en moins nous
n'avons pas été compensés nous avons été
compensés sur trois es2 façon et après
plus rien donc c'est vrai que ça n'aide
pas ça n'aide pas à avoir une gestion
une gestion et êtes malgré cela et bien
nous avons porté le projet de
médiathèque fait signer tous les tous
les travaux c'est moi qui ai porté ce
projet de médiathèque et j'ai été très
soutenu ce billet n'était pas n'était
pas tout à fait d'accord avec ce projet
les dix ans qu'il coûtait beaucoup
d'argent en fait il a profité à toute sa
population essentiellement à
saint-claude 5,6 ronan saint-claude ne
donne pas ne donne pas un centime pour
la médiathèque c'est la communauté de
communes qui l'a financé et nous avons
eu des subventions extraordinaires que
nous n'avons plus maintenant pour les
équipements donc pour moi la communauté
de communes
c'est un bon échelon pour répondre à des
besoins sur un grand territoire qui a un
sens tu es de même demain nous
soutiendrons nous soutiendrons résister
au gel
piscine couverte non rappelle perrin me
dis gentiment que c'est un serpent de
mer
mais oui mais l'argile du crown en parc
dans le jura depuis 25 ans c'est vrai
mais l'argent qui est un serpent de mer
pour financer voilà merci monsieur
monsieur pons est très en retard en
temps de parole donc la doc raphaël
perrin fait de l'ingérence dit
jean-louis millet il vous apporte son
soutien plus ou moins explicite en
disant je démissionne si c'est monsieur
millet si c'est frédéric pons et qui est
élu maire de saint claude
je reste à la présidence c'est un petit
coup de pouce qui vous a donné là est ce
que c'est vraiment bien normal que le
maire de semonce elles interviennent
dans l'élection de syncrude
il est président de l'intercommunalité
les légitimes
je crois que raphaël perrin est tout
simplement déjà tourné vers l'avenir
et effectivement l'acte de
l'intercommunalité c'est l'échelon
stratégique de tous les projets du
territoire y compris ceux de saint
claude voilà et je pense que c'est
important que saint claude quelles que
soient les résultats reprenne sa place
au sein de cette intercommunalité
d'abord elle est attendue elle est
attendue parce que c'est un moteur c'est
une ville centre c'est une ville sous
préfecture
et c'est peut être la plus grosse erreur
du mandat de jean louis millet
d'avoir fait la politique de la chaise
vide parce qu'effectivement exact par
exemple la piscine sera financée via
l'intercommunalité ça peut pas être
autrement
et est ce qui a été toujours promis et
ce qui est encore promis eh ben vous
verrez que avec de nouveaux élus qui
tiennent leurs engagements
on ira au bout et que cette piscine elle
se fera enfin je veux dire juste sur la
piscine
elle se fera aussi l'avis de 5 l'autre
participent financièrement parce qu'elle
en sera le bénéficiaire principal jamais
mis alors la piscine la médiathèque
normalement la ville de saint-claude
sous la plume de francis lahaut avait
promis plus d'un million d'euros c'est
bien ça il je pense pas pardon à
millions depuis son voile as qu'est-ce
que vous avez payez ce que vous ce que
vous ce que ce que le maire précédent
s'était engagé à payer nommé du coup
l'état l'état à verser la compensation
donc ils s'en sont bien sorties et voyez
on a bien fait de pas trop sortir notre
argent puisque l'état est venu abondé
derrière c'était un très bon coup pour
les finances de la ville
mais vous avez oublié vous avez oublié
même quelque chose de très important
dans le pl et le blanc des prône
plus gros projet à la fois culturel et
touristique c'est quand même le musée de
l'abbaye un musée d'une qualité
extraordinaire que j'ai réalisé leur nom
premier mandat de a jusqu'à z sa volée
ça le sujet le seul à ollioules ça vaut
la peine d'aller à sakho ne serait une
journée extraordinaire où nous avions
décidé la création de solutions
nous avions laissé l'atelier couture se
moquer du rien que pour le musée ça vaut
la peine d'aller à saint claude donc
monsieur pensais juste à un mot encore
sur l'activité et du tourisme a avoué et
l'interco donc puisque le tourisme et
l'interco ça peut aller aussi de paix
vous êtes à peine en retard et puis je
passe la parole pour la conclusion
d'accords sur le tourisme c'est
l'exemple parfait de ce que l'on peut
mener comme projet partagé au sein d'une
intentionnalité parce que on a une
complémentarité sur ce territoire entre
le plateau qui est pourvoyeur de savoir
faire les plateaux
des hautes combes qui nous offre des
paysages magnifiques et cette ville de
saint claude dans sa centralité avec sa
culture on a des plus beaux outils
culturels de la région bourgogne franche
comté qui s'appelle la maison du peuple
et la fraternelle et moi je suis
convaincu que dans la recherche de
l'attractivité de ce territoire
ça c'est un outil majeur et c'est une
vraie force pour nous donc il reste un
peu plus de deux minutes dans cette
émission nous passons maintenant à la
conclusion l'ordre donc c'est le masne
en fait que l'ordre d'arrivée le 15 mars
on commence ça a été tiré au sort par
jean-louis vous avez 30 secondes je
surveille le chronomètre
alors monsieur procès prône le
changement écouter le changement
pourquoi pas mais le changement c'est
pour être mieux qu'avant donc il n'a
aucune promotion de programmes sortir la
vie d'isolement rhône est l'attractivité
une ville plus verte
nos pavés cet hiver ils sont tous
reverdit monsieur pons s offusquer des
pavés qui verdissent vous avez une ville
verte sur les pauvres plein de monsieur
poncet et puis la saison culturelle donc
le changement si c'est pour être mieux
d'accord mais elle sait pas le cas et
nous enfoncent dans le trou dans tous
les domaines et puis 188 juste
simplement monsieur eddy monsieur qui
veut faire de la culture a déjà décidé
de supprimer tout le budget de la saison
culturelle qui est absolument fabuleuse
pour les taux n'est là il a déclaré en
réunion publique
on les connaissait maternelle la parole
maintenant justement frédéric pons et 30
secondes pas plus et on se dépêche oui
alors moi je crois que et je rejoins
encore une fois ce que nous ont dit les
cinq lots john et le sanclaudien on a
soif d'avenir dans cette ville ont il
faut qu'on regarde devant nous le passé
est le passé
regardons devant nous on a certes
peut-être des faibles des faiblesses
mais on a aussi beaucoup d'atouts pour
faire bouger cette ville et la faire
bouger tous ensemble francis lahaut
c'est vous qui fermé le bal à nous
n'avons pas parlé de la transition
écologique et nous avons beaucoup à
faire et nous avons des propositions
très concrètes aussi s'agissant de ce
domaine très important que la crise oc a
révélé comme étant une des
préoccupations essentielles des français
et des sanclaudien bien sûr nous n'avons
pas parlé de la participation pendant
nous allons décider de l'avenir de notre
ville
avec ou sans les habitants nous nous
mettrons en place des structures pour
qu'ils puissent décider et nous n'avons
pas parlé de la solidarité
saint claude est la ville la plus pauvre
du département merci beaucoup merci
beaucoup francis lahaut merci messieurs
d'avoir fait le déplacement donc de
saint-claude jusque chez nous à besançon
merci de votre attention et n'oubliez
pas tous les soirs à 18h france 3
franche comté organise les débats
spécial élections municipales second
tour merci de votre attention bonne fin
de journée le journal dans quelques
instants
[Musique]